oh we didn't get to this Carol basket
killed her husband mark has some
interesting theories he was asking
beforehand do you think we all think she
killed her husband right how do you
think she did it do you think it was
meat grinder check this real quick these
are the Tigers this is how you know she
killed her husband let me give you this
[ __ ] right here
this is a hundred percent fact are you
filling up a bar I know I got something
for you since I got something for you
there's a great guy Robert Moore did a
he did a podcast about Joe exotic and
what everything was going on there just
didn't get the same level of popularity
but he had done one so he is a great
Twitter thread and I read some of the
tweets but one of them is this this is
the 21st he is a great Twitter thread
you can check it out it's Robert Moore
our OBE RTM oor underscore look closely
at the restraining order Don filled out
against Carol his signature doesn't
match the one on the power of attorney
which handed Carol to control in the
event of his disappearance
when I asked Carol about this she said
he could barely read her write anyway
and you look at the signatures
completely different Sun different bro
he signs one Don Luis and the other
signature is signed Jack Donald Luis
whoa
that's wild that's a wild this [ __ ]
this murderous [ __ ] she's a murderous
[ __ ] and she's not gonna get punished
in the sense of jail but I feel like for
a girl like this one her reputation is
making the money that's almost worse
than jail for him that's like the great
hell point
her whole thing is built on a house of
Lies of I'm such a good person I'm
rescuing animals oh my husband
disappeared no what happened no no I'm
I'm just out here caring about cats in
rescuing cat and she comes out of this
look and the worst and now everything is
falling apart around ain't nobody's
important big animal rescue after this
piece he didn't take their sponsorship
away I'm sure I know IP didn't catch it
what do you sponsoring this [ __ ] for
did you look into this at all that's a
great point that is a fantastic just put
the word rescue on it and you were like
I this thing's my girl
it out like PETA just just supported
them because it had the word rescue did
you look into anything they're not in
great conditions these animals remember
the [ __ ] tiger drinking the water
that was so shitty before I found out
she killed her husband I was like oh
that must be like doctored footage
you're not gonna make a tiger stick his
[ __ ] neck through something to drink
a little bowl of water like oh my crazy
name a great point that prison wouldn't
be the greatest punishment for her yeah
we look at it because we want justice
but reality this is justice the greatest
punishment would be destroying her
reputation because that's what she cares
the most about she wants the love of the
people she wants the love of the people
she wants to be upheld so she actually
got out of this the worst she got
exactly what she deserved because this
is hell for her everybody saying she
killed her husband like it's a [ __ ]
fact like every I haven't heard a single
Carroll Baskins defense at all and
that's the only time I you look on
Twitter for any opinions you can find
multiple opinions there's [ __ ]
who think the world is flat nobody care
Alaskans didn't kill her there's no flat
earther out there there is no one even
flat earthers are like yo look at the
facts no crazy man likely this is pretty
obvious brother truth is right there a
little research guys come on
[Music]